WHAT'S UP GAMERS
IT'S GAMING TIME
ya'll thought i was scared of a video game made for children??
i don't think so
i'm gonna play the game, and i'm gonna beat it, i'm gonna kill it
and it's gonna be easy
aaaibebibiebiebiebe
alright let's go
okay this should be great
i'm already touching my-
HOW AM I SUPPOSED TO DO IT
my fingers are not-a long enough
why are my finger not long enough
there we go there we go
VR is great guys, definitely buy a VR headset it's working seeming-less-ly - thats a word -
okay okay it works okay now it works
okay
it's all cool right?
are we still going?
alright cool
look at it, this is working pretty well
okay summer night three and this is where the fox come and i have to keep my eye on the fox
and that's fine
can i drink
SLURP SLURP
SHUT UPPP STOP CALLING ME I DON'T CARE ABOUT THE INSTRUCTIONS
I DON'T CAREEeeEeEEeEeE SHUT YOUR PIPPYPOOPYPAPIPOOPIPAPPA
GOdDAmit
AND YOU--
WORTHLESS
look how fast i can change cameras now
this is way better there
look at how fkin fast i am brah
alright where's the jungle brother - there he is
alright there you are
I SEE YEOUW
I SE- I ??? where'd the chickin sh!t go?
where's the sexy mama
there she is, there's my girl
THAT'S MY GIRLL
she's freaking me with her eyes
i can't wait to see her *richard*
okay
there she is - HE* is
help me
im looking at you
i'm looking at you
alright where's the chicken
where's my chicken ba- SHE'S COMING
she's coming to papi <3
she knows what she wants and she wants to get it
i get it
but this time i'm not pulling any strings
i'm not pissing in anyone's pants
AY
AY CHICKEN
yOU wAnNa COmE tO mY HOuSE ???
TOO BADD!!!
TOO BADd MISTER CHICKEN!!
you dumbB
WOW lookat that chicken
alright alright i forgot about YOU
alright we're gonna be ready
we're gonna be ready
i'm ready as freakin -- you could ever be
alright
YOU better not
i'm looking at you
I'm looking at you so f-kin dude
oh the door was closed.
AAAAHAHHAHAHHAHAHAHHAHAH
AAAAHHAHA
STUPID FOX
go back to Norway
the land that no one--
AAAAAAAAHHHHHHHH!!!!! AAHAFJAKDFJ
AAARGARGARGHRKG
STOP !!! STOP STOP STOP
CHICKEN?!
GET A JOB YOU PIECE OF CRAP
okay we're good
everything is good we're not doing too bad ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)
i'm doing pretty good
plenty of power left, we're gonna have a good night :^)
it's gonna be a good night
literally where' s everyone? i don't see a single soul
okay we cannot do this
ther is hope in Sweden
my meatball is protection
oh that means someone moved
CHICKEN
CHICKEN STOP IT
WHY DOES SHE KEEP COMING
that sexy bicc
alright
oka - AY! AY what are you looking at
what's he doing there? you're not supposed to -
who are you?
what the?
that's a coin
should i be scared of him?
nahH
oH GODdaMit it's him agaim
what do i do ???
okay he's still there
WHERE IS EVERYONE
WAAAGHAJYAKJAFADJDKJ
WHY DID HE EVEN--
I KNEW HE WAS THERE
it was JUST to confirm that he *was in fact* there
godDAmiT
where's the --
YOU son of a ssSOCcer mom
i'm touching that thing as soon as my nipples fa-
can you STOP
im SO DONE with all of this
WHAT
WHAT DID THAT MEAN?
DOOR IS CLOSED! sOrRy
SORRY
nOt OpEN~
CAN YOU LEAAVE !!!!
CAN YOU LEAVE MYADKAJDKFJAL
THANK YOU
gODdAm they pissed me off dude, i don't even feel happy
alright yay it's my reward
what do i get?
ow that taste good
so there's night four
brAH
what is this? parts and service? alright let's try this
for the sake of a change
alright i played these, i'm --
AAAA JESUS
"welcome back to Parts and Service"
"Oh, no, it looks like Bonnie's guitar is out of tune and must be calibrated"
okay
"first, we must access the harmonization module located in the secondary throat pipe"
"to access the throat pipe, both eyes must be removed and it must be as precise as possible --"
--when removing the eyes from respective sockets"
why, or what else are gonna happen?
"- - left eye, and carefully remove it from its  socket"
okay Mister Bonnie, let me remove the eye
"Great job, the - "
YEET
AAAAENRRHFAHGRHARGKHJEESUS
WHAT THE fReAKyMuRKy
you did nothing but laugh
"Welcome back to parts and service"
"oh no, it looks like Bonnie's guitar is out of tune and must be re-calibrated"
"first, we must acce -- great job"
"deposite the left eye in the cleaning recepticle on your left"
AAARARGAGWAAAARGAHRGH
WHAT THE HELL IS THIS
oh, LEFT!
WHY DIDNT HE SAY IT
dumb game
sub guy: (give up )
"welcome back to parts and service"
yes
okay alright
on the LEFT
"well done, now firmly grip Bonnie's RIGHT eye and carefully remove it from its socket"
oh
alright let's actually follow the instructions this time
"deposite the right eye in the cleaning recepticle on your right"
"good job"
"-- to open Bonnie's faceplate, carefully press the two buttons located on either side on Bonnie's jaw"
"When done correctly, you should hear two small clicks"
????? what do you mean ?????
okay lettem pressing~
WAJEABLAAPOPPIE
"Press the blinking button in Bonnie's secondary throatpipe to enter calibration mode"
he's got the throat pipe
okay lemme just press the little button
there it is i pressed the button [Bonnie starts playing the guitar ]
okay that's not too bad
"Something is not right, one of those notes is out of tune"
"you may press the button again to replay the audio check"
"press the coloured button that corresponds to the incorrect note"
okay
oh it's definitely the second one
"press the blinking button again to verify your work"
okay well i guess he's playing the -
[visible confusion]
pppfffffWHATTHEHELL
heck there's no tension
im just doing it
alright BAM
[subguy is tired sorry it's the same monologue :^)  ]
WHATTHEHELLAMITOPATA
WAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAA
????????????????
alright this is not the game for me
"are you having fun yet? that is great to hear"
alright what is this then?
dark rooms
let's go
what is this?
night terror
what the hell did i just do?
why can't i play it
okay here we go
close doors, grab and release with triggers
wow what is this?
oh my god this is freaky
hey
oh god
hello?
okay shut --
AKRGALKGRJAGAGRH
shut your mouth, i'm trying to play a game
what is this??
im closing the doors
AY
close the door
there we go
GODAMIT
HEY
listen up you piece of cr@p
i don't ca-
HAKAEHGAHIAEHGAE
GOD
YOU
FRICC OFF
i never played this i don't know the rules
and they just jumped in my face
EXCUSE ME ??
EXCUSE ME
who's doing that
you're in the drawer -- he's in the drawer
llknmkn ??
I CAN'T MOVE
i physically cannot move
my hand is lost
i lost my hand
fck this i want out
i literally --
YOU FRICC OFF
i mean so far nothing bad has happened
i did it
i actually did it
i can't see anything
alright
is this correct?
don't scare me
don't --
yay~
"great job"
"Bonnie is in tune and ready for his solo"
alright
"let's close him up"
"simply replace both eyes in the same order that you remove them, then close up the face plate"
"and we'll call it a day"
then we'll call it a day, you hear that Bonnie boo?
bam
there you go you can see now
wait
he didn't tell me to do anything else
and i'm calling it a day
alright i guess? i'll? press these?
ASGAKRJ
"Well done. That concludes your parts and services task"
"See you next time"
dude i like your knees
alright. cool. i did it
i did it
are these meat balls?
they actually have meatballs
in the game
AORJGH
okay lets --
let's see what chicka has
"welcome back to parts and services"
"there has been complains about chicka's smell"
"sounds like chicka has been rummaging around the kitchen again"
YOU
"-- food particles from chicka's exterior and place it into refuse bin on your right"
wait what was i supposed to do?
alright
algalrharhlr
ahh my baby
that's right my sweet savory  baby
in your KNEE??
you have on in your knee??
"Good job. Make sure chicka isn't hiding any other treats inside her beak"
"you should open her beak. Carefully press the two buttons located on the sides of chicka's head"
cheeka have you been cheating?
okay alright here we go
AAAJEEBALEEBA
"--looks like chicka has picked up some unwanted friends"
"to clear the infestation, apply the ????????? chemi spray to chicka's exterior"
"press the button under the -- avoid inhaling the chemi spray"
"exposure to cleaning, disinfecting, and chemicals may result in respiratory problems, skin, or --
-- eye irritation. Good job"
"Now reattatch chicka's upper arm, hand, and cupcake plate"
what the hell?
this?
alright
there you go
arm, hand, and cupcake plate
"well done"
easy
"oh no, it looks like chicka needs another dose of the chemi spray"
alright that's fine
"do not let the infestation spread"
"be sure to give the chemi spray button another push as needed. Return the cupcake to chicka's plate"
where the hell did the cupcake go?
"return the cupcake to chicka's plate"
AHH GODAM but it's running around
CUPCAKES DON'T RUN
COME BACK HERE YOU SNAKE
"-- place the cupcake on the plate"
IM TRYING
CUPCAKE
I CAN'T --
come here
"please place the cupcake on the plate"
"Good job"
"Chicka is ready to serve pizza and hugs to the kids again"
"take a complementary slice of pizza for a job well done"
rlplrlrplrplprlprlplrprlprlprlplrpl
i take a slice?
i feel like i cannot go back there
i don't know --
oh there
"eat it"
"Delicious. See you next time"
aaaawwww chicka didnt cheat with me
i thought me and chikka would get a lil bit frikka
( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°) ifyouknowwhatimean ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)
"welcome back to parts and service"
"It looks like one of our guests left a personal item on our star attraction"
"Let's return in to the lost and found"
HaHaHaHa
"Carefully, grab and remove the child's hat from Freddie and get a good hold of it"
come on Freddie
"Give it another firm tug"
"Good job"
that's right Freddie
"Now place the hat in the lost and found bin on yor right"
"While we're at it, let's make sure there's nothing else stuck inside"
"To access Freddie's chest cavity, grab Freddie's bowtie and pull it outwards"
oh that's cute
"Well done"
"Freddie's chest cavity is now open"
"Remove the child's watch and place it in the lost and found bin"
"Be careful not to touch any of Freddie's sensitive wires"
it's alright
"Good job. It appears there's a child's shoe wedged behind Freddie's music box"
"The music box must be removed"
are you kidding me?
"-- to access the child's shoe"
"Gently grasp the music box and extract it from Freddie's chest cavity before the safety latch descends"
where's the music box?
is this it?
"Carefully place the music box on the worktable on your left"
"Great job"
"To reset the safety latch,  press the button located on Freddie's --
-- Now, remove the child's shoe and place it in the lost and found bin"
ow f!@# i can't reach
oh
oh come on
i can't reach
my hand
HAUEHAUEHAAAA
GODAMIT i can't go that way
that's not fair
alright let's do one more
alright i'm ready
STOP CALLING ME
OHGOD they're moving everywhere
you are there too
who's moaning like that?
you gotta be fast on the door, man
OH YOU SNAKE
i'm ready
COME DOWN
come down you -- here
you can have a cupcake if you come
i ain't afraid of you st--
HAAAAAHHAHA
BITCJ
WAAGAGAHEKGHAKSJAJGA
are you kidding me?
are you actually kidding me?
im done
hope you guys enjoyed Five Night at Freddie's
this has been an epic gaming time and smash like and subscribe and share with all of your friends
and subscribe
especially
wHaATt?? you never played Tuber Simulator??
pPpffFFfssHSHSHtt
you know it's fun right?
i'm not supposed to give my opinion
but give it a try
and then you can tell me if it's good or not
not convinced yet? oKAy
i'll cut you a deal
the game is available FOR FREE
and that's a great price !!
*tuber simulator music*